I I'm questioning why is nobody talking  about us over the media  I am nobody like I'm just like mother  trying to save my family because my kids  were taken for me when they were little  because I fought for them medical  freedom because so it sounds like the  children were taken away for for reasons  of neglect and this is the person who  knows we should have a new election I I  don't go there okay but I want to tell  you this guys  like a joke but please Arizona I love  Arizona I love all of you I love you  Stephen I voted for you okay this is not  about hate uh Love and Hate You Know  What Love Is to say no to wrongdoing you  know and and please try to understand  those people how upset they are yeah  yeah everybody's very upset because  they're candidate lost and yet they want  a new election because of that if we won  it was fair if we lost it was Rick